i think i was in sixth grade fifth grade
seventh or eighth grade high school high
school but that feels
late to me i asked a bunch of my
coworkers
when they first had the talk not like
the sex talk but the talk about how
babies get made
from a scientific perspective honestly
for someone who just successfully
gestated and delivered a human baby i
know
an embarrassingly little amount of like
how
my egg was fertilized even if we don't
remember it super well
we were likely taught it so
how does fertilization work
oh god okay
sex happens after the ejaculation
happens
the little sperm swimmers kind of like
do do do do do like mini numerous sperm
it's a bunch of them swimming up there
like going really fast
[Music]
and there there are so many that are
like looking for the egg
it's weird because i feel like you don't
really hear about the egg the egg is
very passive and just like
fertilize me and like all the sperm is
like the one doing all the work
everyone i talked to told me similar
stories that
all had a lot of holes and it might be
because of what's inside these
[Music]
right so it's often modeled off this
fairy tale
where you have the knight in shining
armor
going to save the damsel in distress i
think most of us have heard some version
of that story and it's just
it's just not it's not true it's not
factual nadia johnson
and lisa campo engelstein co-wrote a
paper about how the fertilization story
were taught
often centers on the male perspective
in it they analyzed popular textbooks
used from middle school's medical school
keeping an eye out for gender biased
language
i ordered some of them on ebay
[Music]
this book describes only the sperm's
role in fertilization
300 million sperm are released some are
attacked and
many simply die along the way only one
sperm can fertilize an egg in other
textbooks
the female body's role is described
using only
passive language if an egg is present
there's a good chance of it being
fertilized or
if an ovum is present the sperm swarm
around it
and penetrate those layers the books
show the sperm actively swimming
surviving and penetrating while the egg
just sits there it's sending these
really problematic
messages about what it means to be male
and female
and who has agency and who is passive
the truth is fertilization involves two
equally important reproductive systems
collaborating in an
awesome two-player adventure real quick
before we start
there are different ways of making
babies for different types of people
in this video we'll be focusing on the
fertilization story between male and
female reproductive organs
that story starts with the eggs journey
beginning
in the ovaries once a month
during ovulation a mature egg bursts out
of the ovary
a finger-like membrane at the end of the
fallopian tubes
scoops that egg up and other membranes
pull it towards the uterus
it's a complicated necessary trip
and for the best chance of fertilization
millions of sperm enter the vaginal
canal
around the same time some go
in the complete wrong direction and it's
game over for them
early on the ones that go in the right
direction
encounter a more acidic environment than
they're used to
that acidity in the vaginal canal can
harm a few sperm
but the seminal fluid they're ejaculated
in acts as a sort of shield potion
protecting them and while some textbooks
describe
parts of the female reproductive tract
as a place that sperm
never make it out of or are attacked by
they don't talk about
the ways in which the female body
actually helps
after the sperm travel through the
vaginal canal they enter
the cervix the environment of the cervix
can be really helpful
it enables the sperm to survive for a
little bit longer and then it
facilitates the migration of the sperm
then sperm swim rigorously towards the
egg
but let's just say that they're not
michael phelps it has this tail and you
think
oh this tail must be responsible for
it's swimming
from the cervix basically to the egg and
we know now that most of the motility
is because of the things that the uterus
and the female reproductive tract
is doing to move the sperm along first
during ovulation the thickness of the
fluid in the cervical canal
is thinned out then the muscles of the
uterus contract
propelling the sperm faster than they
could ever swim
toward the fallopian tubes at the same
time
the egg is releasing a chemical signal
that acts
almost like a gps so that the sperm have
a good
indicator of which fallopian tube to go
to
there the egg and the sperm are almost
within reach of each other
the female reproductive tract releases a
cocktail of protein and calcium
which gives the sperm the strength to
beat their tails
harder and swim faster than they did
before
this fluid also helps the sperm weather
away this little cap
and once it's gone they secrete enzymes
that help it
dig through the two layers of the egg's
protective outer shell
i feel like every text we look at had
the word penetrate we think of the word
penetrate as neutral
but think about when we use that
language of penetrate we talk about
forces penetrating the army lines if we
think about war
penetrate is this language of like an
assault of doing
harm penetrate is not a friendly like
welcome in
the egg doesn't just wait around to see
which sperm will break through
it uses chemicals to select the best
sperm
the one that will produce the healthiest
offspring
and its work doesn't just stop there
once the egg and sperm come together
the selected sperm deposits its genetic
information
the egg essentially self-destructs all
of its other sperm receptors to make
sure
no other candidates can get in and it
combines with the eggs
to start forming what will soon be an
embryo
and that is how fertilization really
happens
so if this is the true story why have we
been telling it another way
for so long this
idea of who decides and who the experts
are in the field
in science it's it's been white men for
a very long time
like the first person who ever saw sperm
under a microscope was a man
and he had assumptions about you know
what it was
if the assumption is that the sperm is
the most important
part of the whole puzzle it's not like
that's gonna necessarily be challenged
if all the people at the table are met
eighty percent of all the textbooks lisa
and nadia analyzed had descriptions that
were at least
somewhat gender biased it can be
explained in a fact-based unbiased way
but it you know it isn't always and
until
textbooks start explaining the
fertilization story in a neutral way
the information that gets transmitted to
students will continue to be a mixed bag
what we're talking about is not just
changing language in a textbook what
we're also talking about is systems
that are in place and have been in place
for a very long time
you